hi I'm max mo from FX guide.com for
Wired looking at the tech of making the
Lego Batman movie analogic has another
hit on their hands with the Warner
Brothers the Batman movie but these
films are like really hard to make
Gotham City alone is made up of 220
million distinct Lego blocks all these
blocks have our unique patina each brick
when it's made has a lookup table into
various scratch maps thumb prints dent
maps edge profiles and all the other
effects that makes each one of them
slightly unique it's the best my gosh oh
my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh Batman whoa you don't right
whoa in the film Animal Logic used its
own glimps renderer to produce the
spectacular gotham city by the way that
set alone would be six and a half
football fields wide if it was real the
shop with the largest number of elements
had over three trillion primitives he
will take a bit so significantly larger
than the original lego movie but that
wasn't the hardest part about the film
while technical issues are huge and
something to think about
the real challenge was getting a great
performance from the 1.5 inch tall
Batman toy in the first lego movie the
lead character was imminent he had just
two black dots for eyes but here in the
Batman film he only has really a glowing
area under a cow for eyes all the
performances come from replacement
animation so to deliver his lines every
expression means that one cow pops up
and a new cow is at it you'll never see
the traditional Disney style squash and
stretch animation on Batman's face
even the bending of an elbow if you see
an arm thing that it does so by having
digital Lego blocks being swapped in and
out to make the bending shape of the arm
it's all animated brick replacement now
given how limited this kind of stepped
keyframe approaches for a facial
performance animation director Rob Kamen
and the team at Animal Logic tried
really hard to give the audience every
hook to really believe in the characters
and this shows I think in the non-verbal
acting whence a character is listening
to other characters in the scene the
team of course has to work out how to
Adam
what's being said and do the facial
animation of the dialogue but also they
have to make you question does that
other character that's listening
actually believe what's going on all of
which of course plays into the subtext
of the scene and it's the subtext of the
audience loves now personally for Rob
Coleman rosario Dawson was extremely
valuable in this regard she's the voice
of Barbara Gordon mozzeria acted as much
when she was listening to the other
actors doing their voiceovers as she did
when she was delivering her own lines
which gave Rob these really great
moments of a living thinking Barbara
Gordon especially when she's listening
to the BS of Robin and Batman I can wear
my costume too well luckily for us you
left your costume bagging right that's
perfect it's called the Lego Batman
movie just saying are you such a great
Padre what are you doing I'm trying to
give you a big old hug though you're
attacking me now remote all the acting
has to be delivered with just nine
points of movement for any Lego
character this notion of subtext was
also picked up in the lighting is Batman
moving more towards the idea of a family
which case he moves more into the light
or doesn't want to go off on his own and
which case he steps more into darkness
every shot had its emotional beats
underscored by the lighting this is like
really hard to get right in a real film
when everyone's on set together yet
alone when you're lighting plastic toys
months apart to help bring all this
together department heads met at regular
turnover meetings and for each scene
before they went into production the
director Chris McKay would outline at a
pretty high level where this scene is at
in terms of the characters arc and
development what's going on why the
scene was actually in the movie and what
he wanted the audience to take away from
it and then each of the lighting
animation effects in other departments
would be able to contribute their own
ideas as to how to deliver on that scene
I mean animation is hard I mean it's
really hard keeping performances fresh
and spontaneous is incredibly complex I
guess that's the nature of all animation
but just how hard is it well what's this
simple sight gag
I am so sorry soon as I get back to
Batcave
I will make sure that Alfred puts
seatbelts on there well that took quite
a few takes to get right in fact the gag
of Robin hitting his head on the
dashboard which may be kind of a small
thing but to hit his head in a way that
was deemed funny but not gratuitous took
45 takes and months to do and it was
just seven seconds of screen time well
don't forget subscribe for more behind
the scenes action I might see more
this movie has
I'll be bad 24 with a bad man